all right next next category next
category best best meme
this is going to be a contested category
this is so
[ __ ] the subreddit was just [ __ ]
came out like all right let me let me
see what we got
there is countless so many i don't even
think five or six nominations or
whatever can do this just yeah i'm
pretty sure like going through this is
like when humanity first discovered oil
you know it's just a [ __ ] gold mine
right
you can't lose what are we doing
all right let's find out what the
nominations are
we got four oh there's only four okay so
we got one or three
oh this is one of three
that's what i like to hear very nice all
right so the fourth one is
these two the watching the driftwood i
remember the watching the drift one
was just like we got on r slash all for
this meme yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's how you know it was a
good meme right he's made it on every
song because this was the only
meme as well oh yeah that's right i
think this is the only meme out of all
of these that
didn't wasn't actually upvoted on our
own subreddit but just got spread around
every other subreddit i love this one
though the before and after the entire
episode
i mean this is just the culmination of
the best screen cats yeah right
it's just me made in here yeah all right
let's look at the next page
uh don't quote us quotes
uh lady beard man hug oh yeah i like
that meme like i mean
connor i love this kind of reaction did
you do this on purpose do you remember
doing this
i don't even remember the
[Laughter]
and then we go i love this one the god's
middle finger one the middle finger one
yeah
that one is so good yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah good one that's good so that was
like a good out of context
uh screenshot and also a good meme yeah
yeah
and the last page
i'm surprised i'm surprised this clip
didn't come out to like come out on like
the best out of context clip
yeah put your finger have you ever
fingered yourself and i remember being
like what and then you're
like oh me neither yourself
i [ __ ] love this
this is such a multi-layer that's so
multi-layered that's like you have to be
integrated into the trash tastes like
together you need to understand the law
here yeah yeah and then the american
treasure it was just a fantastic edition
fantastic
it's such a good rate and then this is a
very recent meme
which is really a trash taste made it
really translates my channel meme but i
mean it works it's just the color of me
yeah yeah yeah yeah i guess it's proves
how how like
wide the trash taste lore goes yeah that
uh this counts as like a trash taste
even though it's something like
something i would say is like in the
extended trash taste cinematic universe
i would say
that that's that goes there your
favorite meme
oh man i don't know if i have a favorite
meme because all of these memes are if
we go
i would probably have to say the
watching the drift meme just because
there were so many iterations of it and
it made its rounds so far
i do like the bottom gear one i bought
bottom gear one gear one i really do
like i [ __ ] love that one that's just
a good mate that's just a good pick of
like three mates
yeah yeah yeah yeah that pick could go
on my wall when i'm like eighteen yeah
i was like i remember that boys
i love that one that was great i think i
don't know this is this is different
this is difficult
i also love the [ __ ] i mean this is
just best screen shots yeah um
i love the american trash taste man
because i i feel like that just like
epitomizes trash tastes like
single-handedly motivated me to not get
fat
i was like if i'm gonna look like this i
am [ __ ] not going to get to this
point
health like defect just like the
infamous
this this coming after the complaining
about america moment
category beautiful beautiful right it's
such a beautiful
all right all right what do you guys
think
let's say one you gotta say one there
honestly i think
i'm gear mates i think it's gonna be the
quotes of us three
quotes three i'll quote all right let's
find out everywhere all right
trash takes the water best meme goes to
the quote collage
wow i mean i i this did make the rounds
sorry
i'll read the cards i'll read mine if
everybody is rich then nobody is
broke i remember you saying that i
remember saying this one
and i was immediately one of those
things i was like i hope no one noticed
how stupid that thing i said was
i meant to say something else but i just
said that i totally did not mean to say
that
but it came out and i was like no one's
gonna notice this people notice and then
my one is uh young people are young dumb
and full of calm
that's not even that shouldn't even be
attributed to me because my dad used to
say that
and then yours is if you set your mind
to it you can jack off to anything is
this some trash taste
i don't think this is yours from your
own from my own channel yeah i can't
remember which video it was but what
were the percentages actually
yeah what was the percentage uh the
winner was the winner with nineteen
point nine percent
oh my god oh that was actually quiet
actually if there's twelve and now
that's
the first considerable yeah what was
second place second place was
uh as a [ __ ] t-rex
that was like a perfect combination of
two different means yeah that was that
yeah that's when trash taste in any
memes came together
fifth with 9.5 is there before and after
m types
oh yeah oh yeah i love that one honestly
they're all good
yeah sixth with seven point five percent
was bottom gearings
bottom gear mates oh i wish i was a
little bit higher personally i do wish
that was a little bit higher
ten point two percent one is scott's
middle finger
oh which one came last
yeah the one that came last was number
six
which is uh ladybird's mad hug
oh yeah okay okay i mean
episode i think the one where he like
leans into my mic was a better yeah yeah
yeah personally but
i mean yeah well deserved i guess what
is up those were
so many good memes subreddit doing its
work yeah i hope you guys continue to do
your work